inmensas nubes de humo cubren el bosque
de gijón mientras helicópteros intentan
combatir las llamas esta semana los
incendios forestales han consumido
aproximadamente 1800 hectáreas en tierra
el fuego Se incrementa con el pasar de
las horas avivado por fuertes vientos en
todas las direcciones hasta el momento
se han movilizado más de 750 bomberos
pero no es suficiente y la lejanía de
los bosques hace que el acceso sea
extremadamente difícil Mientras tanto
los bomberos se ven obligados a intentar
predecir la trayectoria de las llamas
estamos reposicionando los caminos si no
logramos contener el fuego ahí eso se
pone a pistola
intentaremos bloquearlo por el otro lado
para que no se propague por ahí pero las
llamas están lejos de ser contenidas tan
solo durante las últimas 24 horas se han
destruido más de 3.200 hectáreas de
bosques entre los municipios de somos y
Santa Elena a lo largo de la ruta un
interminable muro de fuego que a pueblos
y aldeas mientras algunas casas y
graneros se han convertido en cenizas lo
que ha llevado a evacuar a más de 500
residentes de la región por su parte las
autoridades van de puerta en puerta para
asegurarse que nadie se quede atrás la
magnitud de los incendios forestales en
Francia batió un récord en 2022 con más
de 62.000 hectáreas quemadas siete veces
más que el año pasado